hello and welcome to say you're playing
vox Dei the voice of God I guess Boris
Marie arson ok so let's go for my marker
gone offline oops oops yeah yeah I guess
you fall ok I think let's prevent night
before him he can go a phone no i can
actually take that then I'm threatening
before him he has to go Bishop d7 I
guess ok where is he going F for now and
I should have thought about this for a
moment no I can take on c5 should be ok
fo Bishop c5 is ok details and then be
five at least that's the position
but I still should have thought for a
moment yet it was before was too quickly
played yeah this is this is an
interesting reply tix then d takes
itself kind of a weird position ok what
now
and the main issue is that may be how to
do anything else what I'm trying to say
okay let's do this so that there's some
kind of play left in the position before
he shuts it down completely
this is six thought you should take but
okay it's not easy here provides to grab
porn like c5 as the dark squares us a
week but I still felt c6 is not great
yep position will become very very sharp
with some kind of f3 and all hell
breaking loose well that's a good Kings
Indian move you cannot just sit sit down
and then shuffle around you need some
some type of activity going on so what
am i doing now I think I think I
probably have to take
FF three is played to free the rook that
the rook has some play and maybe
activate the dark squared bishop it's
simply what black has to do for
practical chances I'm really not sure
about the objective merit of all this
but he probably I think he was right and
doing it even though I'm objectively
speaking maybe this is not not great for
him okay maybe I can just take time
threatening to take on c6 now I think as
as pawn takes the sb7 so green tea eggs
and then 25 should be very good for me
maybe I should have played that actually
instead of fish should be too even
though okay that's tough
Queen takes at least them is quick it's
um it accelerates my development and I
have a four end of a 4h for businesses
chapters doesn't look bad 4-h floor I'm
sorry when King Agenor now I'm
threatening 95 immediate level which is
not which it does not react to it all
okay hmm ok King edge eight still
threatening on f2
right isn't that isn't so great actually
okay that's proven Knight f6
yeah how do i get rid of that queener
from from f/4 93-95 this would be
fantastic if I can manage quite puzzled
what is thinking about now looks like h5
is the only move anyway I think after
yeah I think I'll do this for 93 95 and
maybe the Queen III if everything else
fails okay if i get to d5 that must be
good position I mean a really good
position
black resigns okay Joe as usual
difficult very difficult stuff okay that
looks normal when tier III authority
play Bishop d7 here to prevent a B form
NTM I should have thought for a moment
if really before is the right choice Wow
the computer has given dis giving a
really cool line here the comp wants to
do this this is cool takes and therefore
while
gay here widest busted I'm busted here
very nice stuff so f 5 here and and now
instead of his f4 key extinct species
heaven amazing so I have to do something
else maybe this rabbit then f400 great
that's great it's a great length Bishop
d7 okay so and here this is interesting
yeah b6 is I think the only move that um
yeah keeps keeps the game going in some
way if I just want to yeah bbbb rock
solid I can just play on or whatever
this and just everything is closed stem
nothing happens this is a failed
interesting but I was surprised about c6
I thought you would take but maybe I'm
I'm misjudging this that's it stuffed
the same yeah I just I just play this
position now and say that this is a week
doesn't this is a person now and yeah
the bishop also might come out I'm
liking this okay this happened yeah now
I'm difficult yeah I thought I can just
take this except i should just calculate
a line yet there I just felt okay I have
to take this anyway so but this is just
winning right technically winning peace
yeah if you move the night that sets
pretty pretty awful and go here or
whatever
hmm okay check it's still a good
position but taking 16 verse was a lot
stronger yeah now this is what's my
initial plan but I couldn't really
figure out okay this is actually good
interesting and this and this okay
that's even better than my g5 but the g5
is not bad it is just designed to
prevent Knight f6 and now the idea is to
go back with 93 and so on interestingly
enough why the computer gives this is
okay well maybe my mighty four squares
also also kind of weak it gives this
line now okay that's not a clear bus
that's not clear yeah it's not clear
only here it gets gets awful because I'm
get him hmm yeah very tough game typical
of this line it's very hard to figure
out for both sides okay well thanks for
watching